This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So many classic movies have been made in downtown Los Angeles, even if they didn't take place in downtown Los Angeles. It's always fun when you're watching a movie that takes place in New York and you spot a palm tree. It's like, I gotcha! Palm trees are just one of the factors that a location scout has to worry about. For most films, they really have to avoid them. Laurie Bolton is a location scout in LA.
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。许多经典电影都是在洛杉矶市中心拍摄的，哪怕它们的故事并不是发生在洛杉矶。当你看着一部设定在纽约的电影时，突然发现一棵棕榈树，这种感觉总是很有趣。你会觉得，哈，抓到你了！棕榈树只是外景制片人需要担忧的因素之一。对于大多数电影来说，他们真的必须避开棕榈树。劳里·博尔顿（Laurie Bolton）是洛杉矶的一名外景制片人。
She's worked on Inception, Heat, a river runs through it, a whole lot of movies. She was the first ever location professional ever asked to join the Academy. You're not the only one. I am the only one the first and the only one, yeah. On location with Lori is producer Avery Troubleman. Lori's job is to find interesting, plot- conducive locations, lots of them. I frequently will show someone over a hundred different options for one location, you know, before they get a sense of what they want. But Scouts also have to make sure that the locations they find are actually usable. So a big part of Lori's job is convincing property owners to say yes,
她曾参与过《盗梦空间》、《盗火线》、《大河恋》等大量电影的制作。她是第一位被邀请加入电影艺术与科学学院的外景专业人士。“你不是唯一的。”“我是唯一一个，第一个也是唯一一个，是的。”在劳里的外景拍摄现场，有制作人艾弗里·特罗布曼（Avery Troubleman）。劳里的工作是寻找有趣、契合剧情的外景地，而且要找很多。她说：“我通常会为某个场景向别人展示一百多种不同的选择，你知道的，在他们真正明白自己想要什么之前。”但外景制片人还必须确保他们找到的地点实际上是可用的。因此，劳里工作很大一部分是说服业主们点头答应，
a part which she is really, really good at. I have a question. Maybe I'll have a ride answer. Okay, the ride answer is yes. Yeah, that's your first one. I just want to show her that she's from Oakland. I want to show her. Lori sweet talked our way up to the top floor of City Hall,
而她在这一点上真的非常、非常擅长。“我有个问题。也许我会得到一个正确的答案。”“好吧，正确的答案是‘可以’。”“耶，这就是你的第一个答案。”我只想向她展示她来自奥克兰。我想向她展示。劳里好言好语地把我们带到了市政厅的顶层，
up to a panoramic view of Los Angeles. So great, River. So LA has its problems, but I think any location person you talk to is just really proud of the city and the variety of locations and how much fun it is to drive around and discover things. From the top floor balcony, we could see the massive city unfurling around us. And Lori pointed out all of her favorite locations.
这里有着洛杉矶的全景视野。景色太棒了，里弗。所以，洛杉矶确实有它的问题，但我认为你交谈过的任何外景制片人，都会为这座城市、丰富的取景地，以及开车四处探索、发现新事物时的乐趣感到由衷的自豪。从顶层的阳台上，我们可以看到这座庞大的城市在我们面前铺展开来。劳里指出了她所有最喜欢的外景地。
There's so much variety here, it's amazing. But even with all the architectural variety of Los Angeles, some buildings just keep coming back on screen, again and again. Those architectural gems are very particular and very kind of binding. It's someone's watching it for like you know 10 minutes going my god this feels so familiar. What is this location? I know I know it and then all of a sudden it's like oh my god that's the Brad very building. The Bradbury building.
这里的建筑风格太丰富了，令人惊叹。但是，即便洛杉矶拥有如此丰富的建筑风格，某些建筑还是会一次又一次地出现在银幕上。那些建筑瑰宝非常独特，也带有某种局限性。有人看电影时，看了大约10分钟就会想：天哪，这感觉太熟悉了。这是什么地方？我知道，我知道，然后突然之间就会觉得：哦，天哪，那是布拉德伯里大楼。布拉德伯里大楼。
Arguably the biggest architectural movie star of Los Angeles. It's one of Lori's favorite locations. It can be modern, it can be period. It's kind of upscale steampunk. The iron work, the open balconies, it's just a beautiful building. The Bradbury made its first on-screen appearance in 1943 in the movie China Girl when it played a Burmese hotel. It played a London military hospital in Whitecliffs of Dover.
可以说它是洛杉矶最耀眼的建筑电影明星。它是劳里最喜欢的取景地之一。它可以是现代的，也可以是古装的。它有点像高档的蒸汽朋克风格。铁艺、开放式阳台，它真的是一座美丽的建筑。布拉德伯里大楼于1943年在电影《中国姑娘》中首次亮相大银幕，当时它扮演的是一家缅甸酒店。它在《多佛的白悬崖》中扮演了一家伦敦军事医院。
It was the background of the film noir style thriller D.O.A. in 1950. Is the Marlowe? Yes. In the 1969 movie Marlowe, Bruce Lee steps into an office of the Bradbury and kicks all the furniture apart. It played an office again in the final scene of 500 days of summer. Nice to meet you. I'm Autumn. It was a movie studio in the artist.
它是1950年黑色电影风格惊悚片《死亡黑标》的背景。是马洛吗？是的。在1969年的电影《马洛》中，李小龙走进了布拉德伯里大楼的一个办公室，把所有的家具都踢得粉碎。在《和莎莫的500天》的结尾场景中，它再次充当了办公室。“很高兴见到你。我是秋天（Autumn）。”它在电影《艺术家》中是一家巧克力工厂。
It was a chocolate factory in a recent commercial for Twix. But the Bradbury's most famous role of all was as the Toy Makers house in the 1982 movie Blade Runner. I love it when it's filling up my stuff. movie Blade Runner. In Blade Runner the Bradbury is a dark moody ruin, which seems like some real Hollywood magic when you see what the building actually looks like. From the outside the Bradbury just looks like a brick office building, at the corner of third and Broadway downtown. Kind of unremarkable, but then you step inside and it's like, ah, there's this great biblical shaft of light shining through it. It's basically a tall narrow courtyard, walled in with terracotta covered with a glass
它在最近的一个特维克斯（Twix）巧克力广告中是一家巧克力工厂。但布拉德伯里大楼最著名的角色，莫过于1982年电影《银翼杀手》中玩具制造商的家。我喜欢它充满我手头东西的时候。电影《银翼杀手》。在《银翼杀手》中，布拉德伯里大楼是一个阴暗、忧郁的废墟，当你看到这座建筑的真实面貌时，这似乎带有某种真正的 好莱坞魔法。从外面看，布拉德伯里大楼看起来就像是一座普通的砖砌办公楼，位于市中心第三街和百老汇的转角处。有点毫不起眼，但当你走进去，就会觉得：啊，这里有一道极具圣经色彩的光柱倾泻而下。它基本上是一个狭长的高挑庭院，四周是赤陶墙壁，盖着玻璃
ceiling and flanked by two iron clanking hydraulic powered elevators, the kind that are still run by human operators. Avery wrote in one when she visited the building. Thank you. There's a reason the Bradbury isn't so many films. For one, it's really beautiful. Its floors are tile, its steps are marble, and each floor rims the atrium with a layer of ornate, wrought iron balcony.
屋顶，两侧是两部发出哐当声的铁制液压电梯，这种电梯至今仍由人工操作。艾弗里在参观这座建筑时曾乘坐过一次。谢谢。布拉德伯里大楼出现在如此多的电影中是有原因的。首先，它真的很美。它的地板是瓷砖的，台阶是大理石的，每一层楼都用一层华丽的熟铁阳台环绕着中庭。
But it's not just aesthetics. You have the balcony as in all of the different levels and you can shoot a cross and down in a catty corner. The balcony is allowed the crew to shoot at many different angles and create a whole range of different moods for various genres. The romantic comedy would probably be straight on. The horror movie would be more shooting up, shooting down, maybe that sense of vertigo. And the Bradbury can accommodate all the film gear.
但这不仅关乎美学。你拥有贯穿所有不同楼层的阳台，你可以从斜对角横向和向下拍摄。这些阳台允许剧组从许多不同的角度进行拍摄，并为各种类型的电影营造出丰富多样的氛围。浪漫喜剧通常会采用平视拍摄。恐怖电影则会更多地采用仰拍、俯拍，也许还能营造出那种眩晕感。而且布拉德伯里大楼能够容纳所有的电影设备。
They just have to get in so many toys, you know, the lights and the boom arm and this and that. But look at the ceiling height, this is great. Also, the Bradbury is near a parking lot, which is surprisingly crucial, because a film shoot involves vans and trailers and tons of people and tons of equipment and the parking lot is the place to put it all.
他们必须搬进来这么多的器材，你知道的，灯光、挑杆等等。不过你看这层高，这太棒了。此外，布拉德伯里大楼靠近一个停车场，这出奇地至关重要，因为电影拍摄涉及货车、拖车、成群的人和大量的设备，而停车场就是放置这一切的地方。
It's also nice that the Bradbury is close to downtown and the crew can just go grab lunch. There's nothing like it in Los Angeles and I'm so glad it's still here. That's Kim Cooper, architectural historian. She brought me back to the Bradbury, along with her husband, Richard Schaeve. We are founders of Esaturk, which is a bus tour company that gives tours of Los Angeles, focusing on architecture, true crime, and literature. Three elements which all come to a head in the Bradbury building. The Bradbury opened in 1893, way before the movie's ever came to LA. And for the record, it's not named after the sci-fi novelist Ray Bradbury.
布拉德伯里大楼离市中心很近，剧组可以随时去吃午饭，这也很好。洛杉矶没有比这更独特的地方了，我很高兴它还在这里。这是建筑历史学家金·库珀（Kim Cooper）。她和她的丈夫理查德·谢夫（Richard Schaeve）一起带我回到了布拉德伯里大楼。我们是Esotouric的创始人，这是一个巴士旅游公司，提供洛杉矶城市观光，重点关注建筑、真实罪案和文学。这三个元素在布拉德伯里大楼汇聚到了一起。布拉德伯里大楼建于1893年，远在电影来到洛杉矶之前。而且顺便说明一下，它并不是以科幻小说家雷·布拉德伯里（Ray Bradbury）的名字命名的。
It's named for Lewis Bradbury, a gold mining millionaire. In the mid-1890s, Mr. Bradbury decided he was going to build building. But his name on it, because he was an important man that built up the city. So, in 1892, Bradbury commissions this big, the old famous architect, Sumner Hunt, to design his building. But Bradbury didn't like any of the plans that Hunt showed him.
它是以一位金矿百万富翁刘易斯·布拉德伯里（Lewis Bradbury）的名字命名的。在19世纪90年代中期，布拉德伯里先生决定建造一座大楼。把他的名字刻在上面，因为他是一个建设了这座城市的要人。因此，在1892年，布拉德伯里委托这位伟大的、著名的建筑师萨姆纳·亨特（Sumner Hunt）来设计他的大楼。但布拉德伯里并不喜欢亨特展示给他的任何方案。
Bradbury, disappointed, turns to leave Hunt's office. But as he goes out, for some reason, his eyes caught by one of Hunt's draftsmen, this young guy named George Wyman. He's 2930. He has no professional training yet. He has an architect and no one knows why. But Bradbury takes Wyman, pulls his sleeve, and says, I have an offer to make to you.
布拉德伯里感到失望，转身准备离开亨特的办公室。但当他走出去时，不知为何，他的目光被亨特的一名绘图员吸引住了，这是一个名叫乔治·怀曼（George Wyman）的年轻小伙。他当时29、30岁。他还没有受过专业培训。他是一名建筑师，没有人知道为什么。但布拉德伯里拉住怀曼的袖子说：我有一个提议要对你说。
Well, that offer is completely impossible and inappropriate. He wants to hire this kid, who isn't an architect, to build this very important half-million-dollar-off his building. And this young guy, George Wyman, is a bit weirded out, understandably, because he is totally unqualified for this job.
嗯，这个提议完全是不可能也是不合时宜的。他想雇佣这个甚至还不是建筑师的年轻人，来建造这座价值高达五十万美元的重要办公大楼。而这个年轻人乔治·怀曼感到有点怪异，这也是可以理解的，因为他完全没有资格胜任这份工作。
And he didn't want it to seem like he was taking business away from his boss. But on the other hand, this opportunity was incredible. It's a near-resistible offer, but George Wyman is an ethical man, and he's also scared to death. And so he does what any good Angelina will do in the very late 19th century, which is he will consult dead relatives. Spiritualism was huge at this time, and George Wyman thought that his deceased brother, Mark, might have some wisdom to offer from the afterlife.
他不想让人觉得他在抢老板的生意。但另一方面，这个机会太不可思议了。这是一个几乎无法抗拒的提议，但乔治·怀曼是一个讲道德的人，他也吓得半死。于是他做了任何一个19世纪末的优秀洛杉矶人都会做的事情——他去咨询了死去的亲属。当时通灵术非常盛行，乔治·怀曼认为他已故的兄弟马克可能会从阴间提供一些智慧。
So Wyman sits down with a planned shed, a precursor to a Ouija port, which wrote out sentences with a pencil when you rested your hands on it. Planchettes would typically be consulted when someone had an issue that they wanted some guidance on. So he and his wife were sitting together saying, what on earth should I do about Mr. Bradbury's wonderful terrifying offer? The planchette overcome with the spirit of Wyman's dead brother began to lose.
于是怀曼坐下来，用了一块占卜板，这是现代通灵板的前导，当你把手放在上面时，它会用铅笔写出句子。通常当某人遇到需要指导的问题时，就会向占卜板求教。因此，他和妻子坐在一起说：对于布拉德伯里先生这个美妙而又可怕的提议，我到底该怎么办？占卜板被怀曼死去的兄弟的灵魂所支配，开始移动。
And it wrote, take Bradbury in a very childish script hand. You will be... Just this nonsense script. And Wyman and his blah, blah, blah, blah. Just this nonsense script. And Wyman and his wife were like, what? And it was when one of the two of them walked around the other side of the table and read it upside down, this palm or type script actually said successful. Take Bradbury. You will be successful.
它用一种非常幼稚的笔迹写道：“接下布拉德伯里。你将……”只是一些毫无意义的字迹。而怀曼和他的……呃……只是一些毫无意义的字迹。怀曼和他的妻子当时想：什么？直到其中一个人走到桌子的另一边，倒过来读，这个手写体或打字机般的字迹其实写的是：“成功。接下布拉德伯里。你将会成功。”
That was a clear enough message for Wyman. He says yes to Bradbury. The design of the Bradbury was directly inspired by a novel, looking backwards by Edward Bellamy, which was written in 1887. But in it, there is a description of a building in the year 2000. The future! What Wyman was trying to do with this building, I think we can answer just simply by reading the passage, a vast hall full of light, received not alone from the windows on all sides, but from the dome. So that's what this building does. And that's why even though the breadberry is quite old by
对怀曼来说，这是一个足够清晰的信息。他对布拉德伯里说“好”。布拉德伯里大楼的设计直接灵感来源于爱德华·贝拉米（Edward Bellamy）于1887年创作的小说《回顾：2000年-1887年》。但在书中，有一段对公元2000年一栋建筑的描述。未来！我认为，我们可以通过阅读这段文字来简单回答怀曼在这座建筑中试图做的事情：“一个充满光线的大厅，它不仅从四面的窗户接受光线，还从穹顶接受光线。”这就是这座建筑所做的事情。这就是为什么尽管布拉德伯里大楼按照
California standards, it feels current. It was designed for the year 2000. It's this blend of styles that makes it an architectural gem. But aside from the occasional film shoot, the building spent a lot of its life totally ignored. This building by late 40s, early 50s is once described as a chicken coop. And that just refers to the dustiness and the sort of untightiness. By 74, this place has really fallen apart. So when Ridley Scott shot Blade Runner in its central atrium, it wasn't actually that hard to make it look so shabby.
加州的标准已经相当古老，但它依然让人感觉充满现代感。它是为2000年设计的。正是这种风格的融合使其成为了一座建筑瑰宝。但除了偶尔的电影拍摄，这座建筑的大部分时间都被完全忽视了。这座建筑在40年代末、50年代初曾被形容为一个鸡舍。这只是指它的灰尘和那种凌乱感。到了1974年，这个地方已经真的破败不堪了。因此，当雷德利·斯科特（Ridley Scott）在其中央中庭拍摄《银翼杀手》时，要把这里拍得如此破旧其实并不是那么难。
A Blade Runner, that was just amazing. That was before we'd actually fix it up, and you can tell that from the movie. This is Adele Yellen. I no longer own the building, but my husband bought the building in the late 80s and he retrofitted it. Adele's late husband, Ira Yellen, spearheaded LA's downtown revival by restoring old historic buildings and turning them into housing and businesses. But the Bradbury was just a jewel and he wanted to work on it and he felt if you build it they will come. So I don't know, they ultimately came, but he did have to use the city to help him.
《银翼杀手》那真是太棒了。那是在我们真正修复它之前，你从电影里就能看出来。这是阿黛尔·耶伦（Adele Yellen）。我不再拥有这座建筑了，但我丈夫在80年代末买下了它并进行了翻新。阿黛尔已故的丈夫艾拉·耶伦（Ira Yellen）通过修复历史老建筑并将它们改造成住宅和商业设施，成为了洛杉矶市中心复兴的先驱。但布拉德伯里大楼简直是一颗明珠，他想对它进行改造，他觉得只要你建设了它，人们就会来。所以，我不知道，他们最终确实来了，但他确实不得不借助市政府来帮助他。
Ira Yellen asked if the city of Los Angeles could find a steady tenant for the Bradbury. He ended up getting the police department. Most of the office space in the Bradbury building belongs to the Internal Affairs Division of the LAPD. Yeah, they're there all the time and they don't mind the filming generally. That's Eric Bender. He now handles all the filming requests for the Bradbury.
艾拉·耶伦询问洛杉矶市政府是否能为布拉德伯里大楼找到一个稳定的租户。他最终争取到了警察局。布拉德伯里大楼里的大部分办公空间都属于洛杉矶警察局（LAPD）的内部调查科。是的，他们一直都在那里，而且他们通常不介意拍摄。这是埃里克·本德（Eric Bender）。他现在负责布拉德伯里大楼的所有拍摄请求。
Well, we do a police drama. We take extra precaution to make sure they know that we're filming and the person running around with a gun, type of thing is not. I get very concerned about that. But filming isn't the priority for the property anymore. Since it's renovation, the tenants needs come first. We try not to bother the tenants too much, so we try to do the filming or not do more than one or two filming projects per month. And generally, this is the case throughout buildings downtown.
嗯，我们在拍摄一部警匪剧。我们会采取额外的预防措施，确保他们知道我们在拍摄，比如拿着枪跑来跑去的人不是真的。我对此非常担心。但拍摄不再是这栋物业的首要任务了。自翻新以来，租户的需求排在第一位。我们尽量不去打扰租户，所以我们尽量把拍摄控制在每月一到两个项目以内。通常情况下，市中心的建筑物都是这样的。
Now that people live and work there, they don't want production crews periodically taking over. These days, film crews can't blow up cars in the street or have 300 zombies stampied down Broadway in the middle of the work day. The downtown revival is a part of why filming is leaving Los Angeles. It laughed.
既然人们在那里生活和工作，他们就不希望制作团队定期接管这里。如今，电影摄制组不能在街上炸毁汽车，也不能在工作日的正午让300名僵尸在百老汇大街上狂奔。市中心的复兴正是电影拍摄离开洛杉矶的原因之一。它离开了。
I mean, there's no feature film shooting here. I've, uh, uh, uh, it's scary. Because as I said, I love living here, and I would like to continuously think in my bed if possible. Location Scout Laurie Balton just spent almost a year scouting and shooting in Atlanta, Georgia, which might just become the new Hollywood. Because I've spent so much time in Atlanta, it's like, I'll look at a movie and go, oh yeah,
我的意思是，这里没有故事片在拍摄。我……这太可怕了。因为就像我说的，我喜欢住在这里，如果可能的话，我希望能够一直在我的床上思考。外景制片人劳里·博尔顿刚刚在佐治亚州亚特兰大花了一年左右的时间进行勘景和拍摄，这里很可能会成为新的好莱坞。因为我在亚特兰大呆了太长时间，就好像我看到一部电影会说：哦，是的，
that's Atlanta, you can't fool me. Atlanta, like a lot of other cities in the South, Midwest, and Canada, is offering major incentives to encourage filming. These tax breaks can save producers millions of dollars. I don't understand how these places are not going broke giving the incentives that they are. Cities like Atlanta are also developing state-of-the-art studios and attracting good production talent. We really need to do everything we
那是亚特兰大，你骗不了我。亚特兰大和南部、中西部以及加拿大的许多其他城市一样，正在提供巨大的激励措施来鼓励拍摄。这些税收减免可以为制片人节省数百万美元。我不明白这些地方提供这样的激励措施怎么会没有破产。像亚特兰大这样的城市也在开发最先进的摄影棚，并吸引优秀的制作人才。我们真的需要尽我们所能
can to keep filming in LA, which would mean making the public more open to the disruptive film shoots and keeping the costs of permits down and adding new tax incentives and to stop developing so rapidly. What's happening in LA is we're losing a lot of our parking lots. They'll tear them down and book-putting buildings up. So that's so funny to hear people bemoan the loss of parking lots. Not people.
把拍摄留在洛杉矶，这意味着让公众对那些会造成干扰的电影拍摄更加开放，保持较低的许可证成本，增加新的税收优惠，并停止如此迅速的开发。洛杉矶正在发生的事情是，我们正在失去很多停车场。他们会把停车场拆掉，然后建起大楼。所以听到人们哀叹停车场的消失是一件很有趣的事。不是所有人。
Location people. There's a difference. We're kind of a weird breed. But however, state-of-the-art studios in Atlanta, Toronto, or Chicago are becoming, there are elements of Los Angeles that cannot be replicated, even on the finest sound stage, like the experience of entering the Bradbury building. It's a place so unique, so remarkable, that after it was built, the draftsman, George Wyman decided to take some classes and actually become an architect. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Troubleman with Katie Mingle,
外景人。这有区别。我们算是一个奇怪的群体。然而，无论亚特兰大、多伦多或芝加哥的摄影棚变得多么先进，洛杉矶总有一些元素是无法复制的，哪怕是在最好的录音棚里也做不到，比如走进布拉德伯里大楼的体验。这是一个如此独特、如此卓越的地方，以至于在它建成后，绘图员乔治·怀曼决定去上一些课程，真正成为一名建筑师。《99% Invisible》本周由艾弗里·特罗布曼制作，与凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）、
Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars, Special thanks this week to Linda Dishman, head of the LA Conservancy. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% invisible. You must go to 99i.org Radio Tapio. From PRX.
萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）和我罗曼·马尔斯合作。本周特别感谢洛杉矶保护协会负责人琳达·迪什曼（Linda Dishman）。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的99% Invisible项目，制作于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的一家建筑与室内设计公司Arxine的办公室。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听《99% Invisible》的所有剧集，你必须访问99i.org。Radio Topia，来自PRX。
Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。本节目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。